there is only one Creator and everything
else other than that is part of his
creation and those two cannot be equal
no one with a right mind who thinks
property would say that the Creator is
like the creation these two things are
are separate this is where Paul had to
break this idea and say that God became
a man you know uh Christ became flesh
you know like us if you look at it
realistically there's the Creator and
there's the creation these two are not
equal and they're not the same even
Jesus said it that if I do nothing of my
own like I don't have any power except
that which the father has given me he
works through me the Miracles that that
he that I do I don't do them by myself